[Musique]
bonjour à tous très heureux de vous
retrouver pour un nouveau numéro de
Parlement Hebdo l'émission qui revient
sur l'actualité de la semaine au
Parlement et pour commenter ce film
riche de la semaine nous accueillons
Yann Boucard bonjour vous êtes député
les républicains du Territoire de
Belfort et membre de la commission des
lois bienvenue sur ce plateau et elle a
une aujourd'hui tous les yeux sont
tournés vers le Conseil constitutionnel
qui va rendre en fin de journée sa
décision sur la réforme des retraites si
le texte est validé par les sages cela
ne signifie pas forcément la fin de la
mobilisation sociale la majorité de
droite du Sénat voté mercredi une
proposition de résolution en soutien aux
forces de l'ordre face aux violences
dans les manifestations la gauche n'a
pas pris par au vote et dénonce un texte
caricatural et puis c'est une première
sous la Cinquième République le
Parlement s'est opposé à la nomination
de Boris Ravignon à la tête de l'ADEME
l'Agence de la transition écologique la
nomination du maire de
Charleville-Mézières était proposée par
le Président de la République
les yeux sont rivés vers eux mais c'est
à l'abri des regards qu'ils vont
délibérer dans quelques heures les 9
sages du Conseil constitutionnels vont
rendre enfin leur verdict sur la réforme
des retraites ils diront si oui ou non
le texte du Gouvernement est conforme ou
pas à la Constitution en attendant la
décision c'est une ambiance de veiller
d'armes que nous raconte Elsa mon dingue
avant
validation globale sont sur partielles
ou sont sûrs total gouvernement et
opposition se prépare à toutes les
hypothèses pour le président de la
République la décision des sages signera
la fin du cheminement démocratique du
texte avec bien sûr l'espoir d'une
validation de la réforme mais pour les
oppositions quoi qu'il advienne ce ne
sera pas la fin du combat si le Conseil
constitutionnel ne censure pas
l'ensemble de la loi alors le président
de la République ne doit pas promulguer
la loi parce que sinon il ne pourra plus
gouverner ce pays ne croyez pas que
parce que demain il y aurait une
décision qui serait prise il y aurait
une forme d'abdication de notre part
nous continuerons à défendre par
quelques moyens que ce soit pas à donner
d'avoir un débouché politique à ce
mouvement qui est né sous nos yeux et
que d'un mouvement majoritaire côté
inter syndical cette fois même si le
Conseil valide la réforme la
mobilisation continuera au moins
jusqu'au 1er mai à la décision
s'appliquera
mais notre analyse de la réforme des
retraites dans son contenu restera le
même c'est dans la forme injuste et
brutale parce que dans son application
et puis l'autre élément c'est que on a
encore la possibilité de s'exprimer
notamment à une date qui s'appelle le
premier mai et la date il doit pour le
faire
les opposants au report de la gellégale
scruteront aussi la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel sur le rip le référendum
d'initiative partagé il serait un
argument supplémentaire pour poursuivre
la bataille contre la réforme des
retraites
vous étiez parmi les 19 députés les
républicains qui ont voté la censure du
gouvernement est-ce que aujourd'hui vous
espérez que le Conseil constitutionnel
invalide cette réforme des retraites
est-ce qu'il peut casser la loi comme il
l'a fait deux fois dans son histoire
dans quelques heures mais ce que je note
c'est que jamais sans doute sous la 5e
République une décision du Conseil
constitutionnel n'aurait été aussi
attendu pronostiqué et finalement
commenter par l'ensemble des Français
parce que c'est vraiment une réforme qui
concerne chacune et chacun de toutes
celles et ceux qui travaillent donc
forcément c'est une décision qui est
très attendue sur réforme qui fait
polémique depuis plusieurs semaines
depuis plusieurs mois aujourd'hui la
réalité c'est que personne ne sait ce
qui va sortir de cette réunion du
Conseil constitutionnel moi je pense
très sincèrement qu'il y aura une partie
qui va être censurée
l'index senior le CDI senior j'ai peur
que le Conseil cautionnel finalement
tout le sucre glace sur un gâteau qui
est très amer parce qu'en réalité ce
qu'on sait c'est qu'il y a très peu de
chance que le Conseil consuel n'annule
la mesure d'âge et c'est la mesure d'âge
qui fait c'est ce qui se passion et
c'est la mesure d'âge qui fait la
mobilisation sociale ça effectivement le
Conseil n'a pas de raison n'a pas de
raison constitutionnelle justement de
l'annuler il n'est pas là pour prendre
des décisions politiques et moi ce que
je voudrais dire en tout cas c'est que
je suis un opposant résolu à cette
réforme des retraites mais je suis
inquiet quand je voulais déclarations
notamment de certains collègues de la
gauche et de la France insoumise pour
être très précis qui remettent en cause
depuis plusieurs jours et en
anticipation le Conseil constitutionnel
moi je suis décide de de valider
globalement la loi ça veut dire vous
vous respecterez vous cette décision oui
je respecterai cette décision évidemment
moi je crois dans nos institutions je
crois dans la République je crois que
notre système n'est pas une dictature et
je le dis par anticipation je ne suis
pas d'accord avec cette réforme des
retraites après le rôle du Conseil
consuel c'est de vérifier cette réforme
est constitutionnelle ou non c'est ce
que vont faire les sages enfin les 9
juges du Conseil national aujourd'hui ni
plus ni moins ils ne sont pas là pour
faire de la politique et ça serait très
grave qu'ils se mettent à faire de la
politique d'ailleurs je le dis je le dis
en tout cas les sages vont se prononcer
notamment sur la sincérité du débat
parlementaire qui a eu lieu sur cette
réforme de retraite est-ce que vous en
tant que parlementaire vous avez une
impression que le débat était sincère
le débat je regrette utilisation du 47 1
qui a limité dans le temps qui a limité
dans le temps nos débats mais comme je
regrette les 20000 amendements de la
France insoumise qui ont empêché
finalement que nous allions jusqu'à
l'article 7 qui qui parlait de cette
mesure d'âge qui était tellement
attendue par les Françaises et les
Français parce que d'ailleurs le
résultat de la motion de censure montre
quoi que nous aurions sans doute pu
gagner ce vote sur cette réforme des
retraites que nous aurions sans doute pu
gagner le vote sur l'article 7 donc je
regrette toutes ces mesures dilatoires
qui ont péché d'aller qui ont péché
d'aller au fond des choses mais après
l'article 47-1 moi je ne suis pas pour
mêler dans la Constitution si ceux à qui
ne va pas il faut changer la
constitution c'est cela que ça veut dire
alors vous dites les sages du Conseil
constitutionnel dont on attend la la
décision impatiemment vont se prononcer
uniquement endroit c'est-à-dire qu'ils
ne sont pas là pour faire de la
politique mais est-ce que tout de même
le contexte politique ne va pas jouer
dans leur décision je ne le crois pas je
ne le crois pas et ça ne serait pas
souhaitable mais il y a deux choses il y
a aujourd'hui la décision évidemment sur
la forme des retraites mais aussi la
décision sur le référendum et moi je
crois beaucoup dans ces décisions sur le
référendum je pense que pour sortir de
cette crise politique de cette crise
sociale nous devons aller jusqu'au
référendum ils doivent valider et en
tout cas je vois pas pourquoi une
validerait pas la demande de référendum
d'initiative partagée ensuite il y a une
mobilisation qui sera pour unir les 4
millions 800000 signatures et aller
jusqu'au vote et je pense qu'il n'y a
que par le vote que nous pourrons sortir
de cette crise et d'ailleurs les
parlementaires de gauche qui demandent
ce référendum d'initiative partagé en
déposé une deuxième demande de RIP qui
est serait plus sécurisé au niveau
juridique vous souhaitez vraiment que
cette initiative de référendum aboutisse
oui aujourd'hui on a appris qui est
bloqué et je vois pas comment on peut
aller au bout de ce mandat nous sommes à
4 ans de la fin du mandat du Président
de la République Emmanuel Macron je ne
vois pas aujourd'hui comment on peut
sortir de cette crise si ce n'est par le
vote je crois que je crois quand il y a
une crise de cette sorte il faut en
revenir aux Français alors ça peut être
le vote certains je le vois appelle à
une dissolution peu importe mais il me
semble que le point de crispation
aujourd'hui c'est cette réforme des
retraites donc je pense que nous devons
aller au vote d'un référendum des
retraites et vous vous feriez campagne
pour ce RIP comme on l'appelle
référendum d'initiative partagée
la première fois pour aider les citoyens
de ma circonscription à s'enregistrer
pour arriver au 4800 exactement j'ai la
gérer peut-être un peu autour de la
première circonscription d'ailleurs et
la deuxième fois pour les inciter à
voter contre cette réforme des retraites
donc ce que vous dites si c'est si le
Conseil constitutionnel valide cette
réforme de retraite la mobilisation
contre ce texte doit quand même
continuer
je ne dis pas cela moi je dis que si il
y a aujourd'hui et demain le référendum
il faudra se mobiliser autrement pour
arriver à mobiliser autour des
signatures je pense qu'on en sera là il
y aura plus le sujet de la mission de la
rue le sujet de la mobilisation pour
avoir les signatures parce que 4
millions 800000 on se rend pas compte
c'est énorme ce rythme a toujours été
fait vous le savez pour qu'on arrive
jamais à ce nombre de signature on l'a
vu sur Aéroport de Paris malgré la
mobilisation nous avions à peine atteint
un million 300000 signatures je crois
mais là c'est une réforme qui est
beaucoup plus concernant pour lancer
est-ce qu'il y a un risque pour vous que
la contestation sociale déjà très fort
ce radicalise davantage on a vu encore
beaucoup de violences ce jeudi en tout
cas il y a un risque que les les
Français à force de ne pas se sentir
entendu nous croient plus en grand chose
donc je pense qu'il faut vraiment qu'on
sort de cette crise de cette crise
politique et sociale je l'ai dit et ce
que je voudrais dire comme sur les
mobilisations qui sont parfois de plus
en plus violentes elles sont dangereuses
à deux égards d'abord parce que je vois
moi dans certaines mobilisations des
factieux qui remettent en cause nos
institutions et d'autant elles sont
d'autant plus dangereuses qu'elles
remettent en cause aussi le message qui
est porté moi aussi des centaines de
milliers de Français qui manifestent
pour porter un message un message social
contre cette réforme des retraites le
problème c'est qu'à la fin dans le JT de
20h on voit quoi on voit les quelques
excités qui cassent qui brûlent qui
agressent nos forces de l'ordre on
entend plus parler du message qui est
porté par ceux qui manifestent de
manière de manière pacifique après cette
étape du Conseil constitutionnel comment
vous voyez à la suite du quinquennat
est-ce qu'il faut un remaniement pour
redonner un nouveau souffle à l'action
du gouvernement est-ce qu'il faut un
contrat de gouvernement avec les
républicains à contre le gouvernement
qui a plus qu'à moi je suis totalement
défavorable évidemment après qu'on se
mette qu'on se mette au travail sur
quelques lois sur des sujets régaliens
je pense à la justice je pense à la
police je pense aller l'éducation
nationale ou à la santé qui est la
préoccupation principale des Français
oui moi je j'appelle au travail au
compte construction sur certains sujets
majeurs mais de manière transparente pas
dans les coulisses pas par manière
détournée on la prend dans la presse pas
avec du débauchage individuel de
certains qui iraient au gouvernement
pour obtenir des quelques marocains qui
ne seraient pas qui ne seraient pas
souhaitable un travail collectif en
transparence oui pourquoi pas après
s'agissant du gouvernement objectivement
qui peut croire notre pays qu'Elisabeth
borne peut faire encore quatre ans
objectivement je n'ai rien je n'ai rien
contre elle tout le monde reconnaît
qu'elle est travailleuse mais la réforme
des retraites la complètement expression
mais cramé son capital politique on a
aujourd'hui un gouvernement qui ne peut
plus gouverner notre pays on se rend
bien compte alors oui justement
le gouvernement est paralysé est-ce que
vous êtes conscient aussi que vous avez
une responsabilité dans cette crise
politique on dit que vous êtes un peu la
force d'appoint de la majorité moi je
suis conscient qu'en juin 2022 si j'ai
été élu député c'est parce que les
citoyens l'histoire de ma
circonscription vous l'un des député
d'opposition ils évoluent vous êtes une
force
de la majorité j'avais un candidat
moderne face à moi que les habitants du
territoire Belfort ont choisi d'éliminer
des premiers tours je pense qu'il faut
aussi savoir d'où on vient et si on est
là si on est député c'est parce que nous
avons des électeurs parce qu'il y a des
gens qui nous ont fait confiance et qui
ont choisi en leur année conscience en
juin dernier si vous avez voulu des gens
de la majorité ils auraient lu les
candidats en marche modem comme ils ont
fait en 2017 ils ont fait beaucoup
d'autres choix moi je ne suis pas un
opposant systématique quand il y a des
bonnes réformes je les vote sans aucune
ambiguïté j'ai voté et j'ai appuyé la
loi de rotation de programmation mystère
de l'intérieur on pourra travailler sur
notre programmation militaire sans aucun
sujet mais après je ne suis pas là pour
appuyer en permanence je sais on a
beaucoup parlé des députés Playmobil
entre 2017 et 2022
je les ai beaucoup critiqué je n'ai pas
vocation à devenir un sinon autant que
j'aille chez moi vous avez aussi été élu
en tant que député les républicains sur
une réforme des retraites est-ce que du
coup on s'opposant à cette réforme vous
n'êtes pas dans une opposition
politicienne non parce que vous savez
j'ai dit pendant toute ma campagne
législative que j'étais opposé de
réforme de la retraite donc j'ai pas été
lu du tout sur une réforme des retraites
après on va être très honnête c'était
dans le programme de Valérie Pécresse
quand on soutient un candidat n'est pas
forcément d'accord avec tout son
programme vous savez je fais partie de
ceux qui ont soutenu Valérie Pécresse
jusqu'à 48 heures du premier tour
réellement moi qui ont fait des réunions
publiques dans des communes aux
personnes ne voulait plus aller et qui
ont collé ses affiches et puis on voter
pour Valérie Pécresse quand tout le
monde l'avait quitté y compris dans ce
qui aujourd'hui nous appellent à être
très loy al moi j'étais là jusqu'au bout
donc si la droite n'avait que des
frondeurs comme moi la droite
républicaine c'est dans une forme est
instant aujourd'hui est-ce que Gérard
Larcher Premier ministre l'actuel
président du Sénat qui est allée
républicains ce serait une bonne chose
pour donner un nouveau souffle au
gouvernement si demain il y a une
dissolution était républicains sont
majoritaires à l'Assemblée nationale oui
ils nous sont en cohabitation donc il y
aura tout lieu d'avoir un premier
ministre les républicains mais si demain
il y a des solutions je suis pas certain
que seront majoritaires mais je le
souhaite on se raccompagne pour on parle
d'un peu loin
alors dans ce contexte de tension et de
violence dans les manifestations et bien
la majorité des droits du Sénat a adopté
mercredi une proposition de résolution
de soutien aux forces de l'ordre et à
les sénateurs de gauche n'ont pas
souhaité prendre par au vote car il
dénonce et bien un texte manichéen on va
écouter les explications de Samia de
chia ce n'est pas un texte de loi mais
une prise de position très politique que
les sénateurs ont adopté mercredi la
droite et le Centre ont largement voté
pour exprimer la gratitude et la
reconnaissance du Sénat aux membres des
forces de l'ordre une proposition de
résolution déposée par Bruno retaillod
suite aux violents affrontements de
sainte Soline qui ont fait plusieurs
dizaines de blessés parmi les gendarmes
et les manifestants contre les méga
bassines face à ce déchaînement nous
avons un devoir nous les élus nous qui
sommes des élus c'est de prendre parti
ça n'est pas de nous taire c'est de dire
les choses de nommer les choses et je
pense que nous devons à la fois prendre
parti et finalement choisir son camp le
camp de l'ordre républicain
ou bien alors le camp d'une certaine
forme d'ambiguïté et même de complicité
le texte a été voté à 250 voix pour et 0
contre car la gauche n'a pas souhaité
prendre part au vote sur un texte quel
juge opportuniste et malvenu déposer ce
texte dans une période où le travail des
forces de l'ordre des questionner c'est
déclaré à ceux qui critiquent le travail
de la police circulez il n'y a rien à
voir or la critique de la police elle
est légitime et elle est souhaitable
c'est même l'honneur d'une démocratie
que d’interroger toutes ces institutions
tout en rappelant eux aussi leur soutien
aux forces de l'ordre les groupes de
gauche ont déposé plusieurs
contre-propositions de résolution les
socialistes ont rédigé un texte pour
dénoncer l'ultra-droite les écologistes
eux proposent une résolution pour
interroger notre schéma de maintien de
l'ordre est-ce qu'on doit encore
utiliser des armes de guerre qui ne sont
plus utilisées dans d'autres pays
européens comme le LBD comme des
grenades de désencerclement qui font
beaucoup de mal qui font des blessés
de quelle manière on doit encadrer
est-ce qu'on doit utiliser
l'interdiction de manifestation je
dirais à outrance comme l'a fait le
ministre de l'Intérieur les écologistes
veulent aussi lancer une série
d'auditions sur les récents
affrontements entre policiers et
manifestants pour l'instant le Sénat
entendu que le ministre de l'Intérieur
sur le sujet
Yann bouquin vous voteriez un texte
similaire s'il a été proposé à
l'Assemblée nationale alors qu'on l'a vu
des policiers ont encore été blessés
hier dans les manifestations évidemment
sans aucun souci mais ce que je regrette
c'est que l'assemblé n'est pas adoptée
il y a quelques semaines la proposition
de loi nous collecte d'horizon Lama
muchu d'ailleurs que je veux saluer qui
mettait en place des peines plancher
pour ceux qui agressent les dépositaires
de l'autorité publique moi je ne suis
pas de ceux qui disent oui je soutiens
mais quand il s'agit des femmes des
hommes qui se lèvent le matin qui
vêtissent le costume de la République et
qui nous protège qui protège les
Françaises les Français au péril de leur
vie je crois qu'il faut arrêter il faut
arrêter avec ces petites nuances quand
on quand on les protège quand on attaque
un policien gendarme mais aussi un
douanier un représentant de
l'administration pénitentiaire en
réalité on attaque la République et moi
quand je vois les images de ce qui s'est
passé à Sainte-Soline oui je pense que
nos collègues sénateurs ont eu raison de
réaffirmer même si en réalité on avait
très peu doutes sur le fait que le
groupe les républicains au Sénat
soutenait les forces de l'ordre mais je
pense qu'ils ont eu raison de réaffirmer
le soutien du Sénat aux forces aux
forces de l'ordre et je suis un peu
surpris de la position de nos collègues
de nos collègues sénateurs de gauche si
ça avait été le groupe insoumis j'aurais
pas été surpris parce qu'ils font partie
de ceux qui pensent que la police
devrait désarmer qu'elle ne sert à rien
qu'elle tue mais j'entends parfois mes
collègues députés communistes être un
peu plus courageux que ce que j'avais
entendre à l'instant alors vous soutenez
les forces de l'homme mais est-ce que
vous êtes mettez tout de même il peut y
avoir aussi des violences de de du côté
des policiers il peut y avoir des
dérapages individuels il faut les
condamner il faut les sanctionner
extrêmement durement je pense je crois
en tout cas il y a pas de violence
systémique il y a pas il y a pas faut
bien se souvenir que depuis l'action
d'Emmanuel Macron on enchaîne les gilets
jaunes on enchaîne les manifestations
des antivaxins qui étaient parfois
extrêmement violentes je m'en souviens
chez moi on enchaîne maintenant les
manifestations contre la réforme des
retraites on a un climat social qui
était épouvantable depuis l'élection
d'Emmanuel Macron sans doute notre pays
n'a-t-il jamais connu cela regardez un
peu dans quel climat évolue les plus les
policiers les gendarmes regardez comme
ils ont été très peu soutenus sous
Christophe Castaner par exemple est-ce
qu'il y a des drames il y a
malheureusement des dérapages il y a
malheureusement des interventions qui
peuvent mal se passer mais globalement
dans leur immense majorité je trouve
qu'on a un travail remarquable de nos
policiers et de nos gendarmes
c'est-à-dire faut pas culculer quelque
chose c'est quand il y a des dérapages
quand il y a des problèmes d'ailleurs
mais y compris du côté des manifestants
c'est toujours à Paris on a un contexte
très particulier aussi avec ici des
Black Blocs des gens qui sont
extrêmement violents chez nous en
province moi j'ai vu beaucoup de
méditations chez moi à Belfort avec
beaucoup de monde dans les
manifestations aucun incident parfois
une poubelle vaguement brûlée mais aucun
incident alors il y a quand même eu des
violences à Sainte-Soline dans les
Deux-Sèvres dans la manifestation de
position un projet de méga bassine ce
type de violence est-ce que c'est pas un
échec de la stratégie de maintien de
l'ordre de Gérald Darmanin
ce serait facile de lui jeter la pierre
moi ce que je vois c'est qu'on en avait
là vraiment des des écolos
particulièrement radicaux j'entendais la
gauche tout à l'heure parler de l'ultra
droite là je crois qu'on est dans
l'ultra gauche je sais pas comment on
peut qualifier ça mais en tout cas des
gens qui sont extrêmement inquiétants
qu'on a vu arriver à Sainte-Soline avec
des armes de guerre qu'on a de rivés
dans des conditions clairement il ne
voulait pas manifester paisiblement avec
des bottes en caoutchouc dans un champ
alors peut-être aurait-il fallu les
arrêter plutôt j'avoue que je fais
partie des de ceux qui ne comprennent
pas qu'on n'est pas essayé des empêcher
d'arriver sur le site mais après quand
je vois ce qu'ils ont fait à Sainte
Soline c'était sans doute souhaitable
qui ne soit pas dans une ville avec des
gens autour est-ce que vous êtes pour
interdire certaines armes comme les
lanceurs de balles de défense ou les
grenades de danse de désencerclement qui
font beaucoup de blessés ce serait une
bonne chose de les interdire ces armes
vous savez on peut aussi se dire que la
police devrait pas être armée qu'elle
devrait aller faire de la médiation
enfin je sais pas quelle médiation on
aurait pu faire Hassan Soline je pense
qu'il faut être très raisonnable sur ce
qu'on dit il faut faire confiance à ceux
qui aujourd'hui sont dépositaires de
l'autorité publique et moi je leur fais
pleinement confiance selon vous la
gauche et un peu complaisante vis-à-vis
des casseurs en ce moment en tout cas on
voit bien que aujourd'hui il y a un vrai
sujet mais après j'ai vu votre émission
de la semaine dernière ou Fabien gagne
me rassembler du tout complaisant avec
les casseurs pour le coup c'est pour ça
que je suis étonné de leur vote cette
semaine je pensais vraiment que les
collègues communistes avaient voter du
coup cette cette résolution en tout cas
aujourd'hui oui la France insoumise est
complaisante avec une certaine forme de
radicalisation il le revendique il leur
revendique d'ailleurs mais moi je dis
qu'il faut vraiment soutenir d'un côté
de forzorn mais il faut aussi soutenir
les manifestants parce que je le
rappelle à
95 99% les manifestants sont totalement
pacifiques et quand vous avez
aujourd'hui quelques black bloc il
dénature le message qui est transmis
dans une manifestation est-ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec Gérard Darmanin quand
il parle de terrorisme intellectuel
d'extrême gauche à propos de la France
insoumise je fais attention moi à
utiliser le moteur horrorisme de manière
mesurée puisque notre pays c'est ce
qu'elle terrorisme on l'a quand même
vécu il y a quelques années je pense que
c'est encore un traumatis notamment
quand on est ici à Paris je suis pas élu
parisien mais j'imagine que ce terme non
ça me choque pas parce que je comprends
le fond de ce que veut dire le miso
intérieur et je suis assez d'accord avec
ce qui veut dire sur le fond j'aurais
juste pas utiliser les mêmes mots qu'il
y a aussi dit qu'il fallait je cite
regarder de plus près les subventions
qui sont versées à la Ligue des droits
de l'homme qui fait partie des
observateurs de ces manifestations et
qui critiquent parfois l'action de la
police vous aussi vous pensez qu'il faut
remettre en cause ces subventions ont
été qui critiquent tout le temps
l'action de la police alors je sais pas
s'il faut remettre en cause les
subventions la Ligue des droits de
l'homme et chaque élu local par exemple
aura en juger moi je suis pas là pour
leur donner des conseils mais ce n'est
pas une association sa croissance si
demain elle sort du périmètre qu'elle
était censée défendre oui on peut le
regarder enfin c'est pas non plus j'ai
vu les réactions extrêmement court aussi
de tous ceux qui défendent avec vigueur
avec des droits de l'homme moi j'ai pas
vocation d'attaquer j'ai pas non plus
vocation à défendre plus que ça si le
ministre de l'Intérieur estime d'avoir
regardé pour ce qui est de périmètre
d'action il a été choisi pour ça par le
Président de la République alors on va
passer au troisième thème de cette
émission et bien c'est quelque chose
d'inédit rien de Boucard puisque Boris
Ravignon ne sera pas reconduit à la tête
de l'ADEME l'Agence de l'État qui est
chargé de la transition écologique le
Parlement a rejeté sa candidature ce qui
est donc inédit le maire et l'air de
Charleville était le candidat choisi par
Emmanuel Macron en vertu du pouvoir de
nomination du président de la République
mais député sender ont refusé de donner
leur feu vert à la recondition de Boris
Ravignon écoutez cet échange tendu entre
un député LR de votre groupe et de vos
cas et Boris Ravignon écoutez en
décembre vous n'aviez obtenu votre
validation qu'à 5 voix près avec un même
un bilan négatif de 29 voix pour et 33
voix contre à l'époque l'un des
reproches qui vous est adressé était
votre choix de cumuler la présidence de
l'ADEME avec vos mandats de mer et de
présidents d'agglomération vous aviez
dit que vous exerceriez vos mandalo sur
votre temps personnel
qu'en pensent les habitants de
Charleville-Mézières et Dardenne
métropole le fait cumuler un mandat
local avec un mandat national peut
devoir un intérêt que le fait de rester
en contact avec le terrain à un intérêt
je crois que certains nombre de de
personnes ou de groupes on cette
position en l'occurrence le cumul de
fonction que je représente et légale il
est tout à fait permis par les textes
Boris Ravignon était le candidat de
l'Elysée proche d'Emmanuel Macron il
s'est rally il a été élu LR il s'est
rallié Emmanuel Macron est-ce que ce
vote et selon vous un revers d'abord
pour Emmanuel Macron c'est la première
fois sur la 5e République que les
commissions de l'Assemblée du Sénat
finissent de finissent par rejeter un
candidat donné par un président de la
République que la réforme de la
Constitution impose
il faut pas juste qu'ils sont un peu
défavorable pour que 60 % assemblée plus
Sénat pour rejeter un candidat je pense
que d'abord s'il n'a pas été choisi
monsieur Avignon moi j'ai vu les
collègues du groupe LR qui qui parlait
j'ai vu pierre Vatin Vincent desker
Jean-Yves Bonny qui ne sont pas des gens
qui sont là pour embêter si j'en choisis
de voter éventuellement ce que je ne
connais d'ailleurs pas le résultat de
leur vote et s'ils ont choisi de voter
contre Monsieur Avignon c'est qu'il y
avait un problème soit sur ses
compétences soit sur effectivement vous
l'avez dit son choix de cumuler la
présidence de l'ADEME et son mandat de
maire de Charleville-Mézières alors les
parlementaires les républicains ont voté
contre cette proposition de nomination
et Boris Ravignon a réagi il dénonce je
cite le sectarisme des parlementaires
les républicains effectivement c'était
son parti d'origine les républicains et
puis il a choisi de rallier Emmanuel
Macron pendant la campagne
présidentielle 2022 est-ce que
finalement c'est pas un règlement de
compte politique des républicains il y a
deux choses d'abord assemblées il
manquait plus de 10 membres de la
majorité je crois qu'on voter je crois
que ça veut dire que aussi qu'il y avait
un sujet au sein du modèle d'horizon
sans doute de renaissance pour la
nomination de Monsieur ravine donc c'est
facile de cracher sur son ancienne
famille qu'on a trahi et puis autre
chose c'est clairement tous ceux qui
nous ont trahi tous ceux qui nous ont
quittés quand la campagne était
difficile au moment de la présidentielle
faut quand même pas qu'ils attendent
trop de notre soutien à un moment où
vous savez quand vous crachez sur les
gens faut pas non plus attendre qu'il
faut attendre la main en permanence
alors Boris Ravignon pour sa défense a
dit oui c'est pas un problème au
contraire c'est un atout de cumuler les
mandats je peux apporter mon expérience
du terrain de Charleville-Mézières
est-ce que pour vous c'est un atout un
problème de cumuler comme ça donc la
tête de l'ADEME un mandat d'une ville
35000 habitants et même l'agglomération
la question c'est est-ce que la présence
de l'ADEME est Amanda à temps plein la
réponse est oui évidemment je n'aurais
pas le droit moi en tant que profiter
d'être députés et à la fois de jouer au
maire de Belfort ou adjoomer d'une
commune de 600 habitants
monsieur radignon pourrait être
président de l'ADEME donc voyager en
permanence que j'ai vu j'ai suivi actu
il y a trois jours je crois qu'il était
à la Réunion et évidemment la dame on
attend sur l'ensemble des territoires de
notre de notre République mais à la fois
il pourrait être maire de
Charleville-Mézières présentes pourquoi
pas encore vice-président de la région
Grand Est enfin il y a un moment il faut
arrêter de se moquer des gens si en
France il y a le nom cumul alors
évidemment qu'on peut accumuler la
présence de l'ADEME et le mandat de
maire de Charleville-Mézières ou alors
on annule la loi sur le long cumul enfin
on fait comme on veut mais on peut pas
on peut pas tout faire en permanence
c'est comme c'est ministre qui volaient
à la fois rester mère de leur commune ça
ne me semble pas souhaitable de toute
façon même au niveau de vous n'êtes pas
pour un retour on a bien compris au
député maire ça non plus parce qu'on
parle de cumul de mandat j'ai pas connu
cette période je pense que je pense pour
être honnête que l'assemblée l'Assemblée
le Sénat en son doute perdu en
compétences avec le fait de ne plus
avoir des élus qui sont qui sont à la
première fois je me sens connecté avec
le terrain sans être mère pour être
honnête mais
la réalité c'est quand je vois notamment
dans ce mandat là où il n'y a pas de
majorité à l'Assemblée la charge de
travail que nous avons je vois pas
comment je pourrais être mère à côté
pour être honnête est-ce que vous pensez
qu'il y a un problème de connexion entre
les députés de la majorité
présidentielle et les territoires
actuellement
en tout cas si le groupe Renaissance a
autant baissé entre deux élections c'est
sans doute qu'il y avait un problème
d'attachement à leur circonscription à
certains qui avaient été élu en 2017
uniquement parce qu'ils avaient la photo
d'Emmanuel Macron mais en réalité vous
savez je pense que c'est le problème de
tout ce qu'on appelle les vagues ceux
qui sont élus sur une vague en 2007
c'était Emmanuel Macron en 2022 c'était
plus Jean-Luc Mélenchon et Marine Le Pen
ou il y aura sans doute le même sujet
avec des gens qui ont été élus à
Toulouse quand ils sont de Paris qui ont
été élus dans le Doubs quand ils étaient
je sais pas de quel département donc il
y aura sans doute ce sujet là pour eux
aussi et ce qui est sûr c'est que nous
au républicains nous avons un ancrage
territorial sinon nous serions plus là
Emmanuel Macron lui est-ce qu'il est
connecté avec le terrain avec les
Français on lui reproche d'être enfermé
de prendre des décisions contre tout le
monde envers et contre tous je crois
qu'il Macron n'a jamais été réellement à
connecter au peuple français en tout cas
ce qui est sûr c'est que le peuple
français n'est plus du tout connecté
Emmanuel Macron et vous pensez qu'il va
pouvoir se reconnecter alors qu'il reste
encore quatre ans de mandat dans ce
quinquennat en tout cas s'il veut se
reconnecter qu'il arrête les petites
phrases mépris isantes et qu'il arrête
les interventions comme celles que nous
avons vécu un jeudi à 13h où tout le
monde attendait quelque chose et nous
expliquer qu'ils avaient fait preuve de
beaucoup de pédagogie et que la réforme
des retraites avait subi un formidable
processus démocratique parce que c'est
clairement pas ce que les Français
avaient ressenti merci beaucoup Merci à
VOUS Yann Boucard d'avoir été notre
invité cette semaine et merci à tous
d'avoir suivi cette émission et à très
bientôt ciao ciao
[Musique]